[Music]
chuck it's that time of year all right
well yes of course it is it's the most
wonderful time of the year
yes
actually
i could have said that maybe
half a dozen times in any given year
because each year
offers
its array of meteor showers each have a
name
and
each one it's it's it's earth plowing
through space junk
except cosmic junk not not human-made
junk so
exactly so so we're coming up on the
geminids
so the geminids is a meteor shower
that shows up
second week of december like december
13th 14th around there sweet and
you might ask i i don't know if you did
but you might ask
why do meteor showers show up the same
time each year you know i i did ask that
uh i don't think you heard me but why do
your showers
show up
at the same time each year
you know because these geminids they're
you know they always show up in december
like what's go what's up with that right
what's the deal with the geminis
the geminis are less popular only
because meteor showers are best viewed
late at night
after midnight when you're just sort of
laying out on a lawn right you know
sipping a drink
and
if it's the second week of december
you're not doing that not the best not
the best time to do that
you know there's a there's a better sort
of user-friendly meteor shower right
that takes place in august and it's
called the perseids the person and
that's like yeah that's the second week
of august every year right and it's
august so you get some lawn chairs you
go out you sit hang out late and look up
and watch the meteors fall but i want to
call attention to it because there'll be
talk about it in the press we we think
it might be a little brighter this year
and we don't think the moon will
interfere uh too much with it so do the
the there are they two different debris
fields that you're going that the earth
is going through
perfect so here's what's going on you
ready
every night
there are meteors
every night doesn't matter when
every night earth plows through
several hundred tons of meteors a day
that is
terrifying
terrifying yes my god man
why would you tell me that
why
would you say that
okay i'm sorry
jeez
people say oh the universe is so
balanced and so perfect it's like no
we're in a shooting gallery oh my
goodness
and and so practically every sort of
shooting star by the way these phrases
refer to the same phenomenon shooting
star falling star
uh meteor right they're all referring to
a
tiny particle
that earth slams into in our orbit
around the sun wow right and we're going
about 18 miles a second
okay
what's that it's like 30 000 kilometers
a second around the sun that's fast and
if you're just minding your own business
out there in space right and earth slams
into you right the our atmosphere will
look like a brick wall yeah it's like
yeah it's kind of like the um
the uh the bug that hits your windshield
you know
that's what these like you know that bug
if that bug if you weren't going 70
miles an hour you know that bug see at
70 miles an hour it's like did that bug
just break my windshield like
what the hell was that you know
right yeah so actually there's research
on bug deaths on your windshield by the
way and there's good evidence that they
die before they splatter
really because the air pressure right
before they hit the windshield because
you have direct air coming up against
your glass
and that pressure is very high
and we haven't interviewed the bugs but
there's
there's suggestions that there's
sufficient pressure to squash them
before they actually get smooshed so
they actually explode from the pressure
and then the
the remnants hit your whips here
but
so all i'm saying is 70 miles an hour a
bug on your windshield is not that much
different from a particle of dirt in the
solar system slamming into our
atmosphere right going
any you know 10
20 30 miles a second okay so so that's
what's going on here so now here's what
happens
we not only have all this leftover
debris
that we plow through every day it's not
just every night this is happening
throughout the day you just don't see it
because the sun is out okay so let's
just be clear
so
as we plow through space
there's a subset of all comets
and asteroids
whose orbit crosses the orbit of the
earth
these are called near-earth objects okay
which is euphemism for stuff that will
eventually slam into earth
right
hit you right
yeah it's like somebody when i was when
i was in elementary school and there was
a kid named martin
and martin
used to uh try to find me and take my
money
and
bully martin okay he was a bully and he
would put his fist
uh and i called it like a near-face
object he never hit me he never hit me
he just held it held it near my face and
said give me your money
and i had a near face object and the
threat the threat of the near face
object hitting me
would cause me to give him my money
okay
and just just for for those young
viewers and listeners that was back in
the day when every school had a bully
and you wouldn't even report them to the
principal they were just part of life
yes right that was just there was no
anti-bullying campaigns like
right they would just okay i gotta get
the bully today i'll go in the back door
sneak around the bushes right
and anti-bully was alternate route home
that was anti-bullying
bully strategy
right
so here's what happens if their comment
what happens with comets as they get
near the sun we all know they grow tails
and tail is a little bit of a misnomer
because
it's just a stream of gas
that extends in the opposite direction
of wherever the sun is
so as they approach the sun
yes it looks like there's a tail
dragging behind them but as they
move back away from the sun
the tail is in front wow
okay
it's in front of their motion so we
think of tails as something that brings
up the rear and here it only does that
one on its way in and on its way out it
brings up the front so so but anyhow
they're called tails we'll leave it at
that what happens is
what happened was
what happens is as these gases evaporate
from the comet there's other stuff in
the comet that's not made of gas that
gets dislodged
okay it's mostly particles of rocks and
debris from the comet
and that just
dangles there it eventually sort of
spreads out along the orbit of the comet
but the comet is like this remember
pigpen from
of course uh charlie brown from peanuts
yeah yeah wherever he was there was this
sort of cloudy debris field
in front of him and behind them and all
around that's what comets are they're
pigment orbiting the sun so so over time
that debris completely
filled
the orbit of the comet wow
cool okay cool so but since the orbit
crosses the orbit of the earth
that means this intersection point
happens the same time every year nice
so we go from just regular meteors in a
given night to a meteor shower where we
have a concentration of this debris
because we're passing through the path
of the comet either ahead of it or
behind it now
if you happen to come by
just before the comet got there or just
after the comet had passed there's an
extra concentration of this debris
and we go from a meteor shower to a
meteor storm
nice you want to watch those good yeah
those those are good that sounds like
that sounds good welcome welcome to the
meteor storm
here i am doing it to your ear while you
look up in the night sky
the meteor storm
you need some call letters for that uh
oh man what what could we uh w-m-t-o-r
um
that's pretty cool so we've identified
the object whose debris we're plowing
through during the geminids all right
and it's a rock out there known as 3200
phaethon
p-h-a-v-t-h-o on phaethon sounds like a
new electric vehicle
[Laughter]
okay so this one was a little bit odd
because it's kind of like an asteroid
that had some outgassing
and but that outgassing helps dislodge
particles so
uh it so it's it's one of the rare
meteor showers that is unambiguously
associated with just a pure asteroid
rather than a comet because comets are
better at leaving debris than asteroids
are
yeah and by the way it's called the
geminids because
the direction earth is moving around the
sun at the time right in front of us is
the constellation gemini
and so your plow the point the radiant
the point that you're headed where
you're going to see meteors emanating
from on the sky is the constellation
gemini sweet and guess where the
perseids come from in august uh
perseus yeah constellation perseus so
that's all that's that's it oh by the
way how big are these you didn't ask
they're about the size most that you see
are about the size of a pea oh no that's
the
the brightest streaks sometimes they
they they're really bright and they
explode at the end nice we call those
bow lights
let me get a let me get a low frequency
uh duck on that one
coming up next bo lights here on wnto
your media shower storm station
[Laughter]
so bow lights could be as big as a golf
ball right that would be a really big
one
so most of these are the size of peas
and sizes of the grains of sand but the
fact that you can see them from such a
great distance in the sky is evidence of
how much energy is being dissipated into
the atmosphere so you're literally
watching them burn up
that's what you're seeing the light
you're seeing is them you're watching
them vaporize through the atmosphere
yeah it's it's a it's a it's a
spectacular death for these particles
that's pretty cool man you died well
meteor you died well
spartan
you must die
exactly
[Laughter]
this is meteor
that's cool man
so at a good meteor shower you get maybe
one a minute looking up wow and a meteor
storm you can get anywhere from tens to
hundreds and in some cases thousands per
minute as has happened in the past
um
1833
was a meteor
storm
that i don't know if i told this story
i'll tell it quick and we'll end with it
because we're running out of time okay
but back in 1833 abe lincoln
was a border in a in a in one of these
you know homes that or that people used
to live in temporarily and
and it was run by a pastor
happened to be run by a pastor and this
is in a small town in illinois and
he
uh you know lincoln was a a
self-educated man he was a learned man
okay he was in his early twenties might
have been 21 i think and in 1833 we pass
near the comet that leaves the leonid
meteor showers the lean these these are
these would emanate from the
constellation leo happens in november
okay so that comet has a 33-year orbit
around the sun
so every 33 years we come near where the
comet just was or will soon be that
happened in 1833
there are
artists illustrations of that meteor
shower with people freaking out looking
up a
mouth a gape and it looks like one of
these chrysanthemum firework displays
right these are people just drawing the
meteors falling out of the sky wow the
pastor
who is bible learned remembered a
passage in revelation that said at the
end of days stars will fall from the sky
sky yes like figs from a tree wow and
land on the ground that and so he says
my gosh everyone wake up repent the end
of the world is near and abe lincoln
comes out and he looks up and he notices
the big dipper is still there and orion
is still there and leo all the leah all
of his
known constellations are still there so
he said no stars are not falling so he
went went back to sleep he said take it
easy chicken little
take it easy
[Laughter]
jesus isn't attacking okay no not this
time
he's pissed but not this time
so anyhow so this by the way that story
was uh retold by
walt whitman who was a friend of abe
lincoln wow by the way it's in walt
whitman's notebooks that's a great story
yeah very cool anyhow we got to call it
quiz there chuck but that's everything
you ever needed and didn't ever know you
wanted to know about meteors and meteor
showers oh i'm glad we had this talk i
love it
on kmtr
w-m-t-o-r
meteor
radio
but you need the folks west of
mississippi right kmtr
right your meteor station round the
clock nice oh right one last one a last
one quick quick quick
so out of time uh back in uh 1999
that same meteor shower that that abe
lincoln saw uh i went to the brooklyn
bridge uh and brought my like
three-year-old daughter with me at one
in the morning and the reason why they
happened really late because that's that
when you look straight up that's the
side of the earth that's moving through
space so
after midnight and into the early
morning hours are the best times to view
it it'll still happen other times but
the best is after midnight anyhow i'm
there and and i'm looking up and then i
see this star appear
and it got brighter and brighter
then it just disappeared
and then there was a puff of smoke
and i said
whoa what was that
and then i realized what i had just
witnessed what's that you know what it
was please don't say there was a
helicopter going down
no no it was a meteor headed straight
forward
there's no streak
we're so accustomed to watching streaks
right right
okay if it's streaking me is it going to
land to your left or to your right oh my
god this puppy oh my god i didn't
realize it until after i mean it would
have been too late for me to i mean it
took me about 10 seconds after i
witnessed this to say oh my gosh that
meteor headed straight for me and that
would not have ended well would have
taken me out plus the brooklyn bridge
yeah
that is the proverbial light at the end
of the tunnel actually being a train
i see the light
take me lord
yup that's exactly what's gonna happen
in about four seconds
that's great chuck always good to have
you here always a pleasure
this has been at star talk explainer
duck knights and neil degrasse tyson
keep looking up
[Music]